here at happy Canyon vineyard it's easy
to mistake Tom barrack for a typical
winemaker you look at the vine the the
vine itself is capable at every level of
growing these kind of berries which he
looks the part meant off and even sounds
like an expert each cluster is hand
sculpted to make just the right umbrella
area to nurture that particular bunch of
berries and as the season goes on and
they become more ripe then the the quest
is getting to that perfect sugar content
of knowing when they're gonna be
harvested
but beric is anything but typical he's a
billionaire investor who made his money
in real estate if I was the most
ignorant guy on the blog he could have
bought a trophy property in Napa or in
France instead he built a vineyard from
scratch on this 1,300 acre ranch near
Santa Barbara Oh buying a great vineyard
to me is the same as competing against
Goldman Sachs and Morgan Stanley in an
auction of a company and my young people
come back and say we're so happy we just
bought this company so that's great what
you do they said well we outbid Morgan
Stanley and Goldman Sachs so you kidding
me
is that that's how you make money is by
paying the highest price on somebody
else's auction lessons learned on Wall
Street applied here in sun-drenched
Southern California
it's exactly like investing you may have
a great year
and you may get a little confident and
think you found the tools and then you
get a little arrogant and that next year
mother nature says let me teach you a
little lesson
berrak started growing grapes at happy
canyon about 20 years ago how did you
decide what kind of a wine you wanted to
make well it's it's like all things I
knew that I had no clue I just knew what
I liked to drink but what I liked to
drink
was anything with a cork I didn't have
the taste level
so I surrounded myself with five or six
of the smartest people who did have
and said you guys figured out for us he
knew who to call
barracks investment firm colony capital
previously owned one of Bordeaux's top
wineries Chateau La Scala this place
this little appellation has exactly the
same characteristics as Bordeaux soil
temperature sugar content at the end of
the season we've got a about sixty
planted acres split between Cabernet
Sauvignon Merlot some Petit Verdot some
kab frog we produce four wines that are
that are a blend of it all
we end up with one and a half two tons
per acre which is not much so a
commercial wine producer would produce
five or six tons per acre because they
wouldn't be calling or curating all
their yield they go for yield so again
it's it's like investing you can buy ten
thousand mobile homes or you can buy one
great apartment in Brooklyn you decide
what you want to do
berrak a dealmaker since the 1980s finds
parallels in business for almost
everything he doesn't happy Canyon like
polo another passion everything I do as
an investor is about risk manager and
the main thing is avoiding disaster so
the game itself became a place for me to
practice risk during the Polo season
from May to September
berrak hosts three matches a week at
happy Canyon and players most of whom
are from Argentina regularly practice on
his two fields polo and why they're too
expensive pastimes
berrak says he isn't too bothered that
the winery doesn't make money
what's more important is having a
project his children can share for
decades to come
plus he points out vineyards have proven
to be great investments if my family is
interested and passionate and continues
to leave it a little bit better every
year than the year before we've been
successful what do you say to somebody
who looks at this and says that guy Tom
Barrack he's raising polo ponies he's
growing wine but he's not doing it for a
living he's just a rich dilettante what
do you say to that person I say come and
live with me for a week if you can keep
up with me doing what I do to make a
living for a week you can then be here
and think that you're a rich till the
time business is a physical sport you
better wake up every day and get out
there and compete because if you don't
somebody with cleats on it's gonna run
right over your back
so I'm not the point of letting somebody
run over my back and not the point of
taking anything for granted
I'm very thankful